so I'm already breaking a roll right up
top here because I have a question for
all three of you so jump in whenever you
feel ready but I know you shoot the
episodes of this show very very quickly
and sometimes you don't have the ideal
amount of prep time for a scene so can
each of you pinpoint a scene where you
knew you had to prioritize carving out
some time to prep for yourself and you
know we could see it making all the
difference in the final product uh I'll
actually start with this one I I feel as
though um the scene that we had it was
it was a one shot for the whole battle
in the Cobra Kai Dojo season 10 uh
season 10 episode 10 season
is gonna make it a thing say it again
hey season 10 you never know what could
happen but I feel like that battle we
didn't have too much time to prepare
just because of all the other scenes and
stunts that we had to work out in that
uh huge elaborate fight but I feel like
that's just the beauty of the show I
mean we we're fast paced moving show and
it showed definitely in the in the
finale I think for me um my fight with
Mary
um Samantha we we actually got like
three days to practice it which is a lot
of time for this fast moving set Madness
so uh we got to really drill that fight
in and that was a lot of fun for me it's
either got to be
uh the like the outside like that big
one or like that that final fight at the
end because that was my first big fight
and I think that
um since everyone else was so good at it
and this is kind of my first one I felt
like I needed to step up my game a bit
and prepare for it
um which was a lot of fun and then I
think the
um bar scene with Mary and I are like
that that Oklahoma Oklahoma bit that was
really
um fun but I remember like really
wanting to
make that a good scene all right Griffin
I'll follow up on that then given the
fact that you are building your karate
skills in the show right now is there
anything you saw another cast member do
where their character is kind of at that
next level already and you put that
thing in your back pocket and you're
eager to try it on a future season I
definitely okay there's a few things
there's one there's that bit where the
Dows remember when like you take show
Low's jacket I don't know but there's a
bit where Joe was just fighting with it
with a shirt or a jacket I think that's
the coolest thing ever yeah
um there's that I think and Jacob I
don't remember but Dallas you fight with
Jacob when he when someone just told him
to do that big flying kick thing and he
just did it like I want to get to that
point where like that would take me like
almost a year to learn and he was like
yeah
I believe in you I think you'll be able
to do it all right when I'm coming your
way with a question now because some of
my favorite scenes in the season are the
ones that you share with Peyton so I
want to know what was it like working
with her as a scene partner what is
something that she did for you on set
that helped you access something in your
own character that you might not have
been able to reach without her yes um it
was so much fun working with Peyton the
whole time we were just in between take
scooping around practicing we did a lot
of dancing and singing random songs
um but yeah we were just goofing around
a lot and I think it I think it made for
like a like a just easy going set
environment and
um it really helped us like get where we
needed to be like chemistry wise and so
yeah we've we've become good friends I
love to hear it all right so it's Dallas
for you I I definitely have very high
hopes for Robbie mentoring Kenny Moore
in the future given what they went
through in season five but if not Robbie
who do you think Kenny would benefit
from spending the most time with in
season six I'm gonna go with Ralph
Macchio you know what I'm gonna go with
Daniel Guru so just because just to get
a new you know look on uh pretty much
the karate side of being you have the
intense side with Cobra Kai and then you
have the very more chill and you need to
relax and focus on balance so I think
just to have a different side of karate
would be great and uh you know it would
also help Kenny not be so aggressive at
times as well I feel like that makes all
the sense in the world and it's almost
like the reverse Robbie they'll take
different paths but they'll still get to
the same sense of balance yep all right
Griffin so I am I'm gonna dump another
going forward type question on you now
so Anthony has definitely made some very
very big strides in the new season he's
gonna hopefully uh hone his karate
skills but also just in terms of
figuring out how much to apologize but
also understand ending when enough is
enough so given how much he's grown in
this season going into season six what
do you think Anthony himself thinks is
his new greatest strength now
I think that um what we really got to
see a lot from the egg scene in episode
7 was that Anthony is or actually you
know even with the ending season and
he's pretty good when it comes to like
planning and strategizing less he's not
like a you know like I think Kenny's a
lot of like a big physical threat
whereas I think Anthony is a little more
like a strategic so I think um
I think that would be really interesting
to see Anthony hone in those skills a
lot more where it's more that he's
um
he's always gotten the plan you know
what I mean like he's and I think that's
why he could really fit well with Hawk
and Dimitri and that like they can like
come up with some nerdy little plan and
then everybody can execute it I feel
like if I gave you Dallas's question the
answer I would want you to say is
Anthony spending more time with Dimitri
I just feel like oh for sure them have a
similar Vibe and I'm kind of loving it
yeah they would they would be such good
friends
all right I gotta let you go I can keep
you here all day but I'm not allowed
huge congratulations on the new season
and thanks yet again for being a big old
bright spot in my TV watching right now
thank you so much oh thank you thank you
so much